we got a more injustice to footage for
you this time is the guys over another
room with a character breakdown of
cheetah the latest female character to
make our way into the game if you like
this video and once you more like it
subscribe to our YouTube channel for all
the latest injustice coverage um so
let's talk about a hatch place yeah
we'll start with the normal she just has
exactly what you expect super fast
strike you know just a ton of normal I
love I love the wasting animates them
yeah overhead and whoa are all my man
such a great girl she keeps you guessing
she has a pretty long room list and then
she has a brooch she has a lot of
strings they can go into bro
says this one here Russia gang probably
my favorite at least and you or do a
couple of different options right there
we go except to do it early yeah that's
what I was messing with it you um yeah
this one leaves you standing it's been a
knocking you down because are these like
was one would will begin put they're all
pretty simple one one two four two three
she is not a high execution a lot of
these are grabs at the end of yeah
there's the standard all dissing do one
two and then hit the grow button and
she'll do a crew so I'll close she
basically just mixes you up with
overheads and loads that are low rewards
are not like launchers they're just kind
of quick strikes that go into throws she
she doesn't kill you with overhead the
moment Crescent doing some damage she
killed you a little bit over time or she
goes into her special moves which she
has Mangrum and it could be me every
good combo
it's a little more juggle focus yes
command right here right small thing
this command grabs just do a big chunk
of damage she doesn't accomplish if you
have a Barbie but it's something you
were saying earlier they're like we have
to command read character and they're
very very just so different
now this can beat anyone standing high
but they conduct so see she had
allograft and just like the high
graphics you can either burn it Alex
came home and in a minute she gets a
cool combo suit never look at the
characters we chose for this you
probably couldn't pick two more opposite
characters in the game it's perfect yeah
yeah it's a great coincidence they are
both the same archetype but they play
totally different so in addition remain
RAM she has this rising move primal rage
which is a great wake up attack it's a
great combo wonder if you can be nervous
for additional damage and this
personally want to cool illustration
yeah that I love the personality for
coming down doing it it's interesting
that you like another feline based
character I have my my archives my life
what can I say like cat based team okay
so that's pretty specific you're not
questioning his loyalty though he's
still loyal to these other team oh
that's here and then that's everything
just you do a quote so then to help her
from fullscreen she adds the predator
pound which is anything for that and you
can hold it down and then raise it when
you want or you can actually pop pimples
so you can thank you phoning out and use
it for movement or you can actually go
into an office you ever come watch you
can look short off
which you can be medium-range shop for
consider longer in shop and office you
can do any of her jumping attacks which
are very very good you start right there
that's a tough one cross Angie on the
Gladys is really really fast right and
her junk attacks are very very strong
where jump one is very fast it'll be
other jump attacks knees does it first
four jump two is actually one of the
rare gem effects a little bit very good
in combos very good for air-to-air
energy jump three have really good range
and is active for a long time so all the
way jump attacks are good they all
complement each other by active you mean
it means that actually will connect for
a long amount of time like her leg is
sticking out and all longer leg is out
it can still connect yes yeah and she
also has a cop if she doesn't lean which
is kind of like a size ticket very very
fast overhead and she can do it at any
time in magenta you can do flow she can
come back and do it and she can do it
from top she can even go the opposite
way so she can count over you and then
dive bomb another way so it's like
Michael said she keeps you guessing in
the air confident and she can be to
permit me to get a copy yeah like we're
gonna get dive into that room you can
cover the entire right now it is all on
six you can anti-air the pounce you can
punish her on block so it's high-risk
but it's the way to get in close like
you can green thumb pouch exactly
yeah right you can get one one into a
combo so these are all ways to kind of
control the sky and then get in close to
then begin your awesome yeah another
neat thing is her for three remember to
wear one it's actually doubled inning
it's an overhead like all four threes
but it it's pretty quick and ask you
this yeah so it's really good for
breaking off which is probably the
number one thing to get salty about
let's be honest I don't know if I put
what I get salty about a minute or two
before
that's something I mean there's 50
things I can something about that is our
safe top 5 and her back Green has a
pretty good range it's probably another
animation with oh it looks after we
awesome yeah and then our character
power is your claws of death and this is
a damaged box for any claw base attack
it turns out a lot of pros there's a lot
of attacks just a lot of robust up close
attacks and it's pretty substantial like
yeah you can keep it a lot a lot of day
a lot of birth damage with that but it
doesn't last long
it does not last too long and has a
cool-down and so the idea is do you want
to activate some fullscreen that's
trying to get in or do you want to not
be pulling it down turn it on
give up your momentum but then you have
it on to it if you're right and you get
your awesome schooling you're going to
do a ton of damage oh we've had a lot of
time when you and I have played where
I've tried to cut it out yeah yeah
absolutely no one hits it hurt and her
super move is also really cool because
she travels fullscreen and it's super
fast so it's a great move if they miss
on and of course like anything we had on
so a typical scenario when Solomon
playing is he'll be fine grab and I dug
it and there you go a lot of trouble
rock that here
yeah just he's one of those characters
where when she has the flow hard and
she's definitely like you got to sit
there and really think about what you're
doing with normally when she doesn't
have meter you have to think about the
air and I think we're dashing but
fullscreen she doesn't have a lot of
options so she has super all of a sudden
symmetry box right excellent
oh good that's pretty good I would say
that's the clue that's the quick rundown
she that she is a lot of throw options
that's the main way she opens people up
that's your main source of damage is
you're going to have a little bit of a
struggle at the mid-range trying to get
in you're going to neither - you're
going to have to jump around and commit
to something dangerous with when you get
in it's your turn and she has a couple
of abilities and ones the show yeah
you've got some very cool
we picked a few again talked about yeah
we're going to show a couple things for
each character only do these break down
what will leave some surprise for people
- I don't actually know we're showing so
I will be careful diamonite again one of
them is she has a torpedo move very very
fast it'll hit almost full train not
quite but almost and this kind of
compliments well I'm talking about it
mid-range where she doesn't have a ton
of options if you're struggling against
maybe small things rain or dead chops
projectiles or something you have this
and it could be meter bridge a pretty
good damage and jail actually notice a
good quarter carry exactly er you very
far away
we're just like slumping cheeks up
and then the second one like outlast in
this loadout and by the way I want to
point out I love the gear that she can
change your tail yeah they're
contemporary yeah another another
character I think one of our best in the
game and I say that among some really
good-looking characters
yeah that the range of gear and like
some of the options it's what I would
not talk about it's a lot
so each character has in their gear
loadout we have an accessory spawn and
then you can look at that and sort of
like what's the iconic thing in a lot of
characters right the Superman crest you
know that sort of thing
first it's your tail we're going to be
out Swamp things is his weapon report
yeah yeah so the work is never maybe
yeah whatever yes we have on this
loadout is air RAM and it just
complements your air attacks which are
already really good it gives her a
fourth air attack grade you can use it
to anti-air and you have to do this you
can use it in combos and it could be
meter burn to do additional damage and
she can kind of bounce up and then we
have another load out which has two of
my favorites so one of the things I
mentioned was some of her lows that
overheads don't really lead to huge
damage they're more a pressure option
right yeah and she has this
it ends with a gravity begin we're lucky
the ability version allows me to run and
then she can actually get Thomas neither
this Factory Wow and that'll leave the
big damage so that actually makes her
low combo starter even more powerful and
then she has the predator crawl where
she will click the crawler on the screen
and it's similar to like a bling a roll
it's a move it's a high-risk move that
you can just do it anytime it's a very
odd Eric yes yes something where if you
feel like I don't think we even need to
say it again I didn't block once I said
it's like moving your roll that kind of
yeah and this is a move that it's very
punishable it's very risky
but the opponent is going to have to
look out for it and you can do it in
real time and you can actually meter
Birgit to get a comment
yeah cool summer gear moves really
complement or play style depending on
you know depending on what you're
struggling so if you have someone that
maybe uses like that news battery keep
you out right just this move would be a
great way to beat yeah
click blow the whole time yeah well yeah
and goes very long time yeah cool what's
often so that is Cheeta pesky awesome
[Music]